In this problem, a given holding chamber
initially contains 50 cubic feet of
unccllorinated water. A 1gallon chlorine
solution container is accidentally
dropped and the full container spills
into the chamber releasing an unknown
amount of sodium chloride, NaCCl.
It is mixed and discharged from the
chamber where measurements determine the
sodium chloride concentration at the
discharge point is now 2.5 mg per liter
as chloride. What was the concentration
of sodium chloride in mg per liter in
the initial chlorine solution container?
Assume no reactions had occurred yet at
the point in time in which the
measurements were taken.
So this is a repost of problem 16 where
I forgot to account for some mole
reactions at the end. So if this looks
familiar to you, that's why.
Anyway, this is an example of a classic
mass balance problem. I don't even think
there's really a reference to mass
balance problems in the reference
manual. The closest I got was looking at
the section on clarifiers, but let's not
worry about that. You can look at it if
you want and see if there's anything
that you can easily
memorize or reference there. But in
general, mass balance equations are a
fundamental subject in water resources
and environmental engineering. So let's
just go through that now. So in a mass
balance we have the first volume time
the first concentration plus the second
volume time the second concentration
equals the third volume time the third
concentration
where V3
could be considered V1 + V2. two.
So let's write out our known for the
problem as we've been given.
So first we can see that volume one is
50 cubic feet
and volume 2 is going to be 1 gallon.
Volume three we will have to sum those
two together once we get them in the
same units. So if we multiply
7.48
gallons over
cubic foot,
we can get just about 374
gallons for our volume one.
This would mean that our total is
374 + 1 equ= 375
gallons for volume 3.
Now for our concentrations
the problem notes that the 50 cubic feet
is uncllorinated.
So the first concentration
is going to be 0 milligs per liter. The
second concentration
is unknown amount. So, we're going to
call that X.
And
C3
is going to be
the chloride concentration
at the discharge point of 2.5
milligrams per liter
as chloride.
We will talk about that later in the
second part of the problem. But right
now, let's plug in our known into the
mass balance equation. So we can say
374 gall
times 0 mg per liter
plus
1 gallon
times an unknown amount of our
concentration
equals
gallons.
or the sum of V1 and V2
times 2.5
mg per liter as chloride.
So our first part of the equation will
go to zero.
And multiplying this out and simplifying
will give us
an x equal to
mg per liter
as chloride
or CL minus. In the original version of
the problem that I posted, uh, this was
my final answer. But a lot of the
comments reminded me that I did not
account for the fact that the question
is asking for the original concentration
of sodium chloride
while my final answer was just in
chloride.
So step three for us,
I guess this is the mass balance
equation we're calling step two. The
known are step one. So step three
is going to be to convert the chloride
into sodium chloride and we can do that
very easily.
So all we have to do is use the
molecular weights to get the difference
in concentration.
So in your civil reference manual,
you can find the molecular weights of
these
on page 301
in chapter 6 and in the environmental
reference manual. You can find them on
page 30 depending on which exam you're
taking. So we can see that Na+ has a
molar weight of 23
and Cl minus has a molar weight of 35.5.
So since we want to convert from CL to
NAC,
we can just construct a simple ratio
with NaCCl on the top and CL on the
bottom or
23 + 35.5
on the top and 35.5
on the bottom, which should simplify
down to about 1.65.
So all we have to do now is multiply
our 937
mg over L
as CL minus
* 1.65 6 5
to get a new answer of about 1546
mg per liter
as NA
instead which will be closest to our
third answer in the list. So again, this
is a very simple mass balance problem
that does require us to do one molar
weight conversion to get the right
answer in the right type of compound
as opposed to just the first number you
get, which in this case is also there to
try to trick you.
So just something to be aware of if the
exam asks you to do more than one step
at a time. But they're both easy steps.
And that's it.